I tried to go to church yesterday I was
really trying to go to church and
literally I'm like waiting for the
church to open and this crackhead sits
next to me and there's some broken glass
next to me and he just starts saying
that basically he's like I'm not gonna
fight you with the glass something like
that and for me I'm like I'm not gonna
sit here to find out he told me he
wouldn't I was like maybe I could stay
but
you know I'm not gonna sit here and find
out and this made me think wow and
I really just think when you see the
quality of women decline like this it
shows and I'm not even saying I'm so
much better I'm amazing I'm just you
know as a group when you see the quality
of women decline like this I think it
shows that
civilization like like we're falling off
as a like as a whole because